NARRATOR 1: This
is a simple image.
But as the saying goes, it
can speak a thousand words.
The man who took this photo
sees this picture as one
that can sum up and
represent an entire country.
And I think it'll be best
to let him tell you why.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR 1: Standard and
Poor's gives countries
independent credit ratings based
on those countries' finances.
The better a rating
a country is given,
the more positively it's
looked upon by investors
in the public.
NARRATOR 1: Reports
that came out
after Brazil's World Cup found
that thousands of poverty
stricken citizens
lost their homes
as a result of new stadiums
and infrastructure.
Billions of dollars
that could've
been spent on
sanitation or education
went to the soccer
tournament instead.
And still, many poor
citizens embraced it.
And this is the
dichotomy that attracted
Jairo to take this photograph.
NARRATOR 1: If you
liked this episode,
click now to find out why
these children are living off
of trash dumps.
NARRATOR 2: About 2,000
people made their living
working at Smokey Mountain,
and thousands more
continue to sift through toxic
garbage to eke out a living.
Many of these
people are children.
NARRATOR 1: And, as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]